[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Hello, everyone.
In our last demo,
we demonstrated
how the electrical
conductivity of silicon
can be changed by over
six orders of magnitude
by adding dopants
that can increase
the number of free or mobile
charges in the material.
Today, we'll show how we can use
light to break electronic bonds
and silicon, and create
free mobile charges.
The principles
we'll be using today
can be applied to
everything from sun screen,
to of course, solar cells.
We'll use the undoped, or
intrinsic silicon sample
from our last demo, and measure
how the conductivity changes
when we shine light on it.
Our set up is identical
to that of last time.
We'll take a piece of
silicon with metal contacts.
We'll use an ohmmeter that we
connect to our sample via metal
wires to measure
its conductivity.
The measured resistance
will be determined
by the conductivity and the
size and shape of our sample.
Finally, we represent
the connectivity
in terms of our measured
values and relate it
to the number of
free, mobile charges,
and the material
properties of silicon.
We'll first measure the
conductivity of our sample
in the dark, and then
shine light on our sample
and see how the
conductivity changes.
Our ohmmeter is hooked
up to our sample,
and we measure a resistance
of around 120,000 ohms, which
is equivalent to a conductivity
of around 0.0002 inverse ohm
centimeters.
Now, let's flip on the light.
We can see that we measure
a slightly lower resistance
of around 40,000 ohms,
but what is light
doing to affect the
conductivity so much.
Let's zoom in to the atomic
level and explore why.
We see here a 2D representation
of a pure silicon crystal where
all the valence electrons
form rigid covalent bonds,
are immobile, and don't allow
the flow of electricity.
This material
structure is identical
to our intrinsic sample
when in the dark,
which has a very
low conductivity.
When light hits our sample,
photons of sufficient energy
can break these covalent bonds,
injecting the formally immobile
electron, giving enough
energy to move around.
The mobile electron leaves
behind a mobile hole,
which can move
through the crystal
by swapping positions with
neighboring covalently bonded
electrons.
This explains why
the light increases
the conductivity of our sample.
Again, our conductivity
is determined primarily
by the number of mobile charges.
Light creates additional
pairs of mobile electrons,
and holes, thus increasing
n and our conductivity.
We've demonstrated that
light is able to generate
fee carriers in our
ultra-pure sample.
The same effect still
happens in dope silicon,
but the light induced
change in conductivity
only creates a small
relative change
that we can't measure
using our ohm meter.
Generating these
extra mobile charges
by breaking covalent
bonds with light
is the source of the
electricity that we eventually
collect in our solar cell.
In the next video, we'll explain
how these light generated
mobile charges will be collected
and converted into electricity.
I'm Joe Sullivan,
thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]